it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to Fox News analyst Raymond Arroyo all
right Ray
graduation season is upon us
they are and Laura we want to bring you
some of the best and worst speeches look
after four years of work graduates
expect big names delivering
inspirational messages to send them on
their way at least the kids at Tennessee
State got a big name in Oprah Winfrey
the message felt more like a reused
Biden speech from a democratic retreat
are the generation that is forced to
depend on body cams to obtain Justice
you've witnessed the storming of the
capital and the death of Civility you're
acutely aware that voting rights are
being gutted women's rights are being
dismantled books are being banned
history is being Rewritten the Supreme
Court is being corrupted the debt
ceiling is being held hostage the
climate is changing the lgbtq community
LGBT plus Community is under attack
take a breath Oprah so your life and
your world suck kids and now your
parents are out tens of thousands of
dollars congratulations you transphobic
slugs you I mean what a what a beautiful
send-off to the class there I'm 23.
what's amazing is you know Oprah Winfrey
is one of the most successful women in
world history made popular uh in a
country that adored her and considered
her beloved and celebrated her it's
amazing how things have just changed
since Oprah you know stopped her
syndicated show it's crazy hmm yeah and
the poor kids at the historically black
college Howard University Laura they
didn't just get an old Biden speech they
got an old Biden delivering it I most
dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy I'm not
saying this because I'm in a black HBCU
I say Wherever I Go
to confront the ongoing assault to
subvert our elections reject political
extremism and reject political violence
protects fundamental rights and freedom
for women to choose
transgender children to be free
did he and Oprah share a writer do you
think Laura I mean the the Howard
graduates are not buying this Malarkey
by the way a few even made their own
signs this one says Biden and Harris
don't care about black people they're on
to the game well I love how Biden said a
black HB
um yeah CU versus HBCU black HB versus a
what a white HBCU that confused me but I
think we can guess Biden's reaction to
all of this Raymond you got more
questions and you ain't black
well you know Laura he it is it's cruel
for him I think to divide these students
based on race and to feed this in
addition to which white supremacy is not
the number one issue facing anybody
including the black community and I
pulled the FBI statistics when 65
percent of violent acts against black
Americans are committed by black
Americans white supremacy is probably
not playing a role there well you can
tell George it's election season go
ahead it's elections that's exactly
that's why he's saying what he's saying
and Georgia Tech actually got an amazing
commencement from Super Bowl winning
Chiefs kicker Harrison butker watch this
sadly we are encouraged to live our
lives for ourselves to move from one
thing to another I can offer one
controversial antidote get married and
start a family my confidence as a
husband and father and yes even as a
football player is rooted in my marriage
with my wife as we leave our mark on
future Generations by the children we
bring into the world
how much greater of a legacy can anyone
leave than that
that was a massive address that's
awesome he's great and and look Lori
your life doesn't have purpose until you
commit yourself and you have children
you know that you can pass your values
on to I mean for me they opened up a
whole new career for me my children I
wouldn't have written children's books
or any of that but for the kids and they
give your career a dynamism it otherwise
would never have and you do have a sense
of purpose
I completely agree that was an awesome
speech good that we're focusing also on
the nice stuff out there and the
inspirational yeah and Laura race is not
only on the minds of some commencement
speakers now MIT is developing a virtual
reality game that allows viewers to
quote confront Prejudice and xenophobia
by assuming the identity of a Muslim on
a plane I'm glad it's not on 9 11. uh
context is important meanwhile another
game called Barnstormers allows you to
experience the virtual world of
segregation oh no Negro League Baseball
they wouldn't let them play Major League
Baseball they had to prove to the world
that the Mages weren't Superior because
they were white and they weren't
inferior because they were black do they
really think the country is this awful
and rotten and racist I mean I guess
they do I mean I guess that's the whole
campaign vote for us because the country
is awful rotten and racist vote for us
look I see the educational value here
but I do worry about focusing on the
sins and the biases and I await the game
of the Asian lady trying to get home
from the subway to her house that's the
that's another bit of a storytelling I'd
like to see in the VR world not not
inspiring as a game and some of those
commencement Duds were horrific Raymond
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else